-How are you, Sarah?
-Hello, my friend.
-It is lovely to see you,
as always.
And you have been very kin
to share with the world
how glamorous your setup is.
You gave a little
behind-the-scenes photo --
-Oh, I sent...to the
segment producer --
Actually, behind what I sent you
is way more taped together
-Yeah, but this right here i
just the -- real nice.
I mean, you got, you know,
one of those plastic bins.
A water box.
Then there you are.
-That's fancy water, though,
Seth.
-That is fancy water.
I feel like anyone who think
you're, you know, living
anything but the high life
knows now they're mistaken
-Yeah.
-It's debate night.
We tape before it happens.
Are you going to, when thi
is over, where --
Are you going to watch it?
Who you going to watch it with
-I am. Right from here
I go to my dad's apartment
and I need to -- it's my tur
to clean out his foot wound.
And bandage it loosely.
And then we're going to
order pizza,
because I'm sure by then we'll
be hungry, and watch the debate.
-What is -- is the foot wound --
Is this something that --
Did he actually hurt it?
Or is this just wear and tea
over a lifetime
of using a foot?
-Just always some kind
of open sore
on the bottom of his foot.
-Uh-huh.
-I don't know.
It's really just become
something I've just accepted
I don't question it.
-Is this a fixable --
-My stepmom's out of town,
so I have to clean it up.
-Is this a fixable wound?
He's going to keep the foot,
right?
-Uh...he's got to do
everything right, you know
but he loves riding his bike
He's got, like,
this adult tricycle.
And he swims all the time.
I mean,
the doctor actually said
it's an option to cut it off
and I'm the only one
in the family
that's team "cut it off."
-[ Laughing ]
-But he's so afraid of,
you know -- he would never
and he's terrified of --
he's so scared of any surgery.
He was supposed to get surgery
on his --
his rotator cuff, you know
-Yeah.
-Because he couldn't even
do this.
Then the doctor said he needed
surgery, and he did it.
He was like...
[ Groans ]
He lifted his arm.
The doctor's like,
"How'd you do that?"
And in his thick Boston accent
he goes,
[ Boston accent ]
"Fear cured me."
-[ Laughs ]
Your dad is a funny --
funny and strange, I feel like
is how you would describe him,
correct?
-Yesterday he sent
an e-mail to --
He's been with the same
accounting firm
his, like, whole adult life.
And then his dad before them
before him.
And he sent an e-mail
that was like,
"Listen, I know we've been using
your firm for --
since 1947, but I just think
it's time to make a change
Also, P.S., can you send m
Trump's tax accountant's
number?"
Which is, you know --
it's soft comedy,
but you've got to give him
credit because he didn't write
like, LOL, or "just kidding,
which is, you know,
the balls-out comedy
when you're not sure.
-He just let them have
to deal with it,
percolate it for a while.
-Just got to trust they know
it's a bit.
-You --
I want to ask about this.
Do you have any expectations
about the debate tonight?
-I guess I'm pretty sure
it will be awful.
-Yeah.
-I have this dream,
like, I wish --
like Biden -- I feel like
any gesture of care
would throw Trump off.
Like, if Biden, right before
they go live,
just was like, went up
to Trump and said,
"Hey, man,
are you okay?"
You know, just like throw hi
off his game.
-That's a really --
-Maybe something like that
It's just so, like --
This is just a terrifying year
I mean, you know -- he's -
Trump knows that the only wa
he stays out of jail
is by being president.
So he's, you know, discreditin
the vote by mail,
he's trying desperately
to get as few people
to vote as possible.
And it's just, like, you know,
his whole cabinet's
like in jail
or convicted or on trial.
It's like, can we just pleas
vote for Biden
and end this
White House-to-prison pipeline
once and for all?
-It does seem like they have
tried to paint Biden
with a bunch of different
brushes.
And one of them is
that he will lead --
he will open the gates
to socialism,
which I think is probably
a surprising thing
for someone like yourself,
who is a Democratic socialist.
You know, it's a real reminder
that had Bernie --
I think that was the fear,
if Bernie was the nominee,
that's what they would
have said.
-Well, clearly the RNC's
talking points didn't change
from when they assumed Berni
was going to be the nominee.
-No, they didn't.
-The fact that, like,
Joe Biden is going to, you know,
make the country socialist
is, like, hilarious.
But also, what do you not like
about socialism?
I mean, I'm a Democratic
socialist,
but so is everybody,
in essence.
Like, the bedrock of our
democracy has socialism.
What do you hate about
socialism?
You hate, you know,
driving on roads?
You hate sending your kids
to public school?
You hate being able to cal
the fire department if there's
like, a cat stuck in your tree
You know?
Those are socialist programs
I mean, listen.
All it is is --
is like, you know, health care
for all and education for all.
So, you don't have to be rich,
you know.
You can still become
a rich [bleep].
It just means that, like,
kids don't have to go hungry
in order for you to do it.
Does that ruin it for you?
You know?
-Yeah, I feel like
yesterday was --
-The best was --
-Especially with the tax stuff
you just go, oh, yeah, you know,
Donald Trump would have stil
been a rich person
if he paid his taxes.
You know, maybe not real rich.
But...
-Whatever.
-That would have been nice
to have that money
to use on something other than
the things that Donald Trump
wanted to buy for himself.
-Yeah.
Like, billionaires,
if they paid their tax
like the same percentage
taxes as, like,
a wait -- a server
at a restaurant --
I almost said waitress.
-[ Laughs ]
-Woke.
I love that --
-Bullet dodged.
-...Senator Tim Scott,
the guy who spoke
at the Republican
National Convention,
and he was like, "If Biden wins,
he's going to turn this countr
into a socialist utopia!"
I just -- it's just funny.
Like, drop "utopia" if you'r
trying to undersell something.
-Yeah, it's a bad word
to use in a negative.
I know one of the things tha
you found yourself doing,
I don't think you were
alone in this
during these last seven months
or so,
was playing a lot
of video games.
Were you a gamer before this
started?
Or did you just have
more time to game?
-I was not.
I mean, the last time
I was a gamer was Nintendo 6
"GoldenEye,"
which I still know every
room of every map.
But when everything shut down,
I was in New York.
And I -- I just went to GameStop
and said, I better --
I'm going to learn video games
So, I bought, like, a used
console and a couple games
and then I just got really int
"Call of Duty: WWII,"
which is great because
you get to kill Nazis.
-Yeah.
-But I played with my --
I have an assistant, Annie
and she moved to New York
with me for that --
the three months I went there.
It was going to be, like,
our last hurrah
before she goes on to bigger
and better things.
And we ended up being quarantine
partners.
And we played "Call of Duty:
WWII" every night.
But when you play against
each other, Seth,
what you don't realize is
somebody has to be Nazis.
-Sure.
-I was Nazis.
-Really?
-Now, me, Sarah Silverman,
I'm against Nazis.
-Famously so.
-As an actor, you have to
sympathize with your character
So, it was like -- I had t
really get under their ski
and be like, "Hey,
these people are trying
to take away our freedom,
our freedom
of exterminating all Jews
and creating a perfect
Aryan race.
And, you know, it was
really fun.
-That's -- that's great.
And so much fun
that it inspired --
you have an idea for a new game?
-Okay.
Activision, if you're
watching --
Does Activision --
Does Activision watch
your show, Seth?
-Uh, I'm sure. I'm sure
someone down the ladder --
maybe not the top of the ladder,
but someone does.
-All right, listen to this
"Call of Duty WWII:
Peacetime."
It's 1970.
You haven't been back to Berli
in 25 years.
But this time you're back.
And you brought your family.
It's going to have amazing maps.
Great restaurants will be a map.
Um...
PTSD flashback.
Meet the grown adult child
you never knew you had.
And, of course, boutique hotels.
-Of course.
What a perfect reason to go back
to Berlin in 1970.
Sarah, your podcast,
this is so exciting.
-Yes, my love.
-This has been --
Podcasts, people have been
doing for a while.
Why are you doing yours now?
It seems overdue, to me.
-I like to do things overdue
-Yeah.
-No, I think it's because
you know...
I haven't been able
to do standup.
I haven't done standup --
other than I went to Ohio an
did standup with Chappelle
which was incredible.
But, besides that, I haven't
done standup in seven months
I haven't gone that long without
doing standup since I was 18
And I needed to put it all
somewhere, you know?
So, I'm doing this podcast
and it's --
it's mostly just me
ranting.
I do take some calls.
But, you know, I just kind o
cover everything, the micro,
like my life, and the macro,
the bigger picture of it all
And, you know, I --
I talk about --
from politics to my pubes
and everything in between.
All four things in between
-I think we would expect
nothing less.
Thanks so much, Sarah, it'
always so lovely to see you.
-I love you.
-I love you too.